-Regina Hall!
Hey! You feeling the love?
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to the show.
-I'm so excited.
This is my first time.
-And that feels weird to me.
It feels like we should have --
-Can I shout-out someone?
-Of course you can.
-Black Thought.
-Wait. Him?
Wait. He's already shouted out.
-I know.
-No, he gets shouted out
every night.
He gets shouted out too much.
-I know, but I know him.
-So do I.
We all know him. Yes.
How do you know him?
-Can I say?
-Of course.
-Oh, okay.
So, he's married to
one of my best friends.
-Oh, okay, good, yeah, yeah.
Of course, yeah.
We love her, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, he's a good --
-Tanya.
-What?
-No. Michelle.
I got him. I got him.
[ Laughs ]
-Tell Michelle --
Yeah, yo, leave it.
-Sorry.
-So, you've known her
for a long time.
-Yes.
-Did you know him
before he was married?
-I did not.
-Oh!
-I'm the reason he's married.
-What?!
-Okay, he might not know this.
Can I tell this story?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Okay, so, quick story.
So, there was a song where the
chorus would be like,
"Just give it here
and don't say nothin'."
And I was obsessed.
I couldn't stop playing
the song.
And I was like,
"Listen to this song, y'all.
He said, 'Just give it here.'
You can't help it.
You got to give it.
Then you're there."
So, we went on vacation,
me and my friends.
And Michelle was like,
"I love that song, too."
And we couldn't stop playing it.
It was over and over and over.
Well, Michelle really couldn't.
And, so, we played it
over and over.
And then they had a concert,
and she went and they met.
-Yeah. Yep.
-Wow.
So you just saw Michelle
from the stage?
-Um, no.
She came backstage,
like, after the show was done.
-That's where you guys met?
-Yeah.
-And was Michelle a model?
What was --
-Beautiful.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Always beautiful. Stunning.
-Stunning.
-Yeah.
So, I mean -- Yeah,
you're lucky she came backstage.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-We'll talk about Tariq
more later.
-Yes, yes, yes.
-But I want to know about you,
'cause I think
we have something in common.
-Yes.
-Growing up -- Is this true?
Because I wanted to be a priest
at one point growing up.
And I thought I heard
that you wanted to be a nun?
-I did. I did.
-Up to what grade
or how old were you?
-High school.
-Yeah, me, too.
-You too.
-Really?
-You're cute.
We would've been bad together.
-We would have been good, right?
Imagine us together?
-Father Fallon.
-Sister Regina?
-Yes.
I loved it.
I loved the whole idea of it.
-What happened?
-Girls. You know what?
I don't -- I think --
I don't know what happened.
I just kind of grew out of it.
And then I go,
"Well, maybe it's not --
Maybe I'm not
getting the calling.
And if I did get the calling,
it'll bring me back in."
-Were you a virgin
up until then?
-Uh, yeah.
Yeah, I'm still a virgin.
Yeah.
-Some of them have
sexual-partner numbers,
which is four.
-What are you talking about?
-You can't do it
if you've had more than like --
In certain sects,
you can't become a nun
if you've had more than
a certain number of
sexual partners.
-I did not know that.
-Yes, yes.
-Wow. So, what's the number?
-That particular one,
it was four.
-I can still be a nun.
[ Laughter ]
I want to talk to you about --
Can we -- Can we talk about
your love of Prince?
-Oh, my God.
-Because I know you love Prince.
-So much.
-We were lucky enough
to meet him
and have him play on our show,
and he was a character.
And, gosh, he's just a genius.
-Sexy.
-But he's also -- Yeah.
Sexy?
-Sexy.
-He really was.
-Yeah.
When did you get into Prince?
-Oh, gosh, I was like 6.
-How could you be into Prince
and want to be a nun?
What a conundrum.
-It was. No pun intended.
No, I saw him doing --
-Thanks for catching that.
I don't even know I did that.
-You did it.
-Conundrum.
Yeah, but I didn't do it
on purpose.
But it -- Conundrum. Wow.
That's great.
-I love that. I love that.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I'm feeling this.
Yeah, we got to hang out.
This is fun.
-So, I saw him on this video
show performing "Dirty Mind,"
and he had -- Remember when
he used to wear the leg warmers
and the underwear
and the trench coat and heels
and, like, eyeliner,
and it was a little --
-Yes, yes, yes.
-He had that on,
and I felt a way.
And I was little.
And I didn't know what
the way was.
You know what I mean?
Because you don't know
what sex is,
but you know that
there's something happening.
And I felt that.
[ Laughter ]
-You felt bad?
-No, I felt that.
I felt that way.
-Oh, you felt that way.
That. Oh, sorry.
-Yeah, I felt that.
-You felt that.
-I felt that.
-You felt that, okay.
And then you go,
"I want to feel that."
-[ Laughs ]
-No, I mean -- No, no, no.
I don't want to feel that,
but I want to feel --
I want to keep that feeling.
-I was like -- It made me happy.
It was a -- I liked it. Yeah.
And then I just had --
Then it stayed.
And then, like, his music --
the "Do Me, Baby."
I didn't know what those words
meant or those sounds.
But I liked it, you know?
-Did you ever get to meet him?
-Yes.
Yes, I did. We had dinner.
Not together,
but, like, at a table, 10 of us,
not alone.
And I started singing, and then
he got up and left the table.
-Wait, wait. Tell me again.
So, you started singing.
-Yeah. We were at the table,
and I started --
I said -- I looked at him
and I said...
♪ Have you ever wanted to play
with someone so much
you'd take any... ♪
And he got up
and he took it and he left.
-He got up and walked out.
-He left.
Yeah, he has a sense of humor.
He came back.
-He did come back.
-Yeah, he is funny.
-Yeah. He said my name.
-He did?
-Yeah.
-When he came back
or before he left?
-No. Onstage.
He played the song and said,
"You like that, Regina?"
-No way!
That's even a better ending
to the story.
-It's pretty great.
-Oh, my gosh. Alright.
-Can we talk about
"Best Man: Final Chapters"?
-Yes.
-Let's do it.
The original "Best Man," 1999.
-Yes.
-And then here we are
23 years later.
You're doing it --
-10 years old
when I did the first one.
-Yeah, you're still playing
this character. Yeah.
And this is your big break,
though, right?
-This was my first movie.
-Yeah.
And was your family
all excited that you got cast?
-My family was excited.
You know, my brothers
went to see it,
and they weren't excited,
'cause they were like,
"Regina, your ass was out."
They were very upset.
'Cause I have three brothers,
no sisters.
-Yeah. And they -- Yeah.
-Your butt cheeks are out,
'cause it was a thong.
I mean, now it's mild.
Everybody's naked everywhere.
But at the time --
-I mean, please, follow me
on Instagram and find out.
-I've seen it. I've seen it.
Father Fallon's at it again.
He's at it again.
-Wow. I was feeling that,
and, you know, I had to do that.
'Cause I was feeling that.
-Yeah, you're feeling that.
-Yeah, exactly.
Well, where does
the story take place?
What part does it pick up on?
-So, we picked up --
We pick up right after --
Like probably two years after
the where the last one ends.
I'm -- You know, I'm married.
I was --
-Good.
-No, I'm happy.
-Well, show it.
-Yeah, I know.
-What do you mean?
Oh, I see.
-No, 'cause I'm saying
she had the arc.
She went from ho to housewife.
-Yes.
Is that what -- Yeah.
She was a dancer.
-She was a dancer
in the first one,
and in the second, we found out
she was doing things for tips.
-Mm-hmm.
-Which is fine.
-Sure.
And now she's a housewife.
-Now she's a mother.
-But that's great.
-And a teacher.
-It's good to have
an arc, right?
-I think it's good to have
the -- She gives good advice.
She's had a long life.
She's had breadth.
Breadth, with
the "D" that's silent.
-Mm. Breadth?
-Is it breadth?
Is that how you say it?
-Breadth.
-Yeah.
-B-R-E-A-D-T-H.
-Yeah. That's a good word.
-Yeah.
'Cause depth doesn't have
the "A."
You know, like death,
but then depth.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry.
The edibles are just kicking in
for me right now.
Wow! Wow!
Death. I want to show this clip.
This clip has breadth.
It has depth.
-Yes.
That was good.
-Thank you.
And it also has
a pterodactyl in it.
No, I'm just -- Here's a clip.
Here's Regina Hall in
"The Best Man:
The Final Chapters."
Take a look at this.
-Every day, you know,
it's just the same thing --
Cooking, cleaning,
prospective-student interviews,
tours.
[ Whispering ] A bitch needs
a change of scenery.
[ Laughs ]
We barely made it here tonight.
-Where's Julian?
-Oh, circling the block,
shamelessly.
Looking for a parking spot.
-Oh, Harper has some good news.
They're making
"Unfinished Business"
into a movie.
-Oh, wow! The Bumper G one?
-Uh, no, my first novel.
-Oh.
Oh, oh.
-What?
-No, that's cool.
I'm just saying,
I'm glad that no one was around
chronicling my college exploits.
-Like when you were a stripper?
-Um, you know,
remember I told you
that was a very small part of
mommy's undergraduate
experience.
-What's a stripper?
-I'll explain later.
-[ Sighs ]
-Yeah. Regina Hall, everybody.
"The Best Man:
The Final Chapters"
begins streaming
on Peacock December 22nd.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show." Stick around.